- La maladie de Lyme n'épargne
personne, aucune région
l'Outaouais, et la Montérégie
antage touchées,
les tiques se propagent de plus
en plus vers le nodes changemen.
Dr AMIR KHADIR, infectiologue-e-
microbiologiste Pierre-LeGardeur
- Parce que les petits mulots,
les chevreuils
qui sont porteurs de réservoirss
naturels de ces tiques-là
migrent tous vers un climat
un peu pue les tiques
se retrouvent souvuvent souvuve,
elles peuvent tout aussi bien
se situer dans des milieux
CARL DUBOIS, vice-président
Asso. qualadie de Lyme
- Les tiques adorent
les endroits qu'on
en arrière des oreilles,
à l'aine, derrière
les genoux, les coudes,
ou en dessous des aisselles.
pourquoi
lors d'une randonnée en forêt,
il est recommandé e moustiques t
de porter des vêtements longs
de couleur.
CATHERINE BRETON, atteinte de
la maladie de Lymeuver mon corps
un jour...
our ceux qui ont été
infectés, rares sont
les ressources. Fatigue
musculaire, migraines, malgré
des symptômes re
à la maladie de Lyme,
Catherine Breton a dû réaliser
du combattant afin d'obtenir
un diagnostic près de 15 ans
plus tard.
- En fait, je me réveillais
le matin, puis j'étais toujoais
jamais reposée. Je suis
retournée consultee consultee c,
mais le médecin me disait :
"Madame Breton, c'est
- Pour le microbiologiste et
infectiologue de Montréal,
c'est le manque de ressources
et de recherche sur
cette mae le mauvais diagnostic.
- Nos outils diagnostiques,ce ss
diagnostiques qu'on utilisait
il y a 30 ans quand j'étais
Et ils ne sont pas très bons.
- Mais plus de ressourcessources
verront le jour. Il y a un mois,
Québec annonçait que
en COVID longue et en maladie
de Lyme seront mises sur pied.
Le Docteur Khadir rappelle que
les pharmaciens peuvent aussi
prescrirnt
d'être piqués.- Tout l- Tout l-s
avec des problèmes prolongés.
ur Khadir,ur Khadir,ur Khadir,u,
Catherine Breton appelle tout
de même à la prudence cet été.
vigilant, en fait, quand on va
mettons faire des activités
en plein air, il faut pas
hésiter à demander à des gens os
examiner
- Ici Louis-Philippe Arsenault,
Radio-Canada, Q